>> Shannon: AND JOINING US NOW
TO SHARE SOME OF HER GOOD NEWS
BEFORE WE SAY GOOD NIGHT,
BETHANY MICHAEL.
HER BE STRONG INITIATIVE IS
WORKING WITH THE GLOBAL
EMPOWERMENT MISSION.
GRAY TABBY WITH US.
I SEE THESE TWEETS ABOUT MASKS
AND LUNCH FOR KIDS AND ALL KINDS
OF THINGS YOU ARE TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER.
YOU’RE THE KIND OF CELEBRITY
WHEN WE SEE YOU LEVERAGING THESE
THINGS FOR GOOD, IT INSPIRES ALL
OF US.
TELL US WHAT YOU ARE DOING WITH
COVID.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
ARE DOING IS SOURCING, BETTING,
BUYING AND DISTRIBUTING
PROTECTIVE GEAR FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE
OFFICERS.
WE HAVE ALREADY DISTRIBUTED OVER
$16 MILLION WORTH OF AID TO
THESE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE HIT OVER 15 STATES AND
WE ARE WORKING DAY AND NIGHT
SECURING THE PROPER MASKS,
HAZMAT SUITS -- WE SET A MILLION
HAZMAT SUITS TO GOVERNOR CUOMO,
200,000 MASS TO
GOVERNOR de BLASIO AND WE ARE
WORKING TO SUPPLY AID NATIONWIDE
TO HEALTH CARE WORKERS,
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS THAT ARE
DESPERATE FOR THIS PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
PEOPLE ARE RISKING THEIR LIVES
TO SAVE HOURS.
>> Shannon: YES.
HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO DO THIS WHEN
THERE’S BEEN SUCH A CONVERSATION
ABOUT TRYING TO GET THESE MASKS
AND PPE ROUTED TO THE RIGHT
PEOPLE IN THE AMOUNT THAT THEY
NEEDED?
>> I JUST FEEL THAT WE CUT
THROUGH THEIR RED TAPE.
FOR EVERY TEN WAREHOUSES THERE’S
ONLY ONE THAT HAS ACCURATE
INFORMATION, AND DISTANT PRICE
GOUGING OR HOARDING.
SO WE ARE GOING ROUND AND WE ARE
JUST HUSTLING, WE ARE NONSTOP
AND IT’S WORKING AND WE ARE
MOVING QUICKLY.
BILLY JOEL DONATED HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS IN AID AND WAS
OUT THE DOOR THE NEXT DAY.
CAMILLA AND
MATTHEW McCONAUGHEY DONATED A
BIG AMOUNT TODAY AND THERE IS
WILL BE OUT THE DOOR TOMORROW.
WE ARE WORKING AND RAISING MONEY
FOR ALL THE POOR HOSPITALS THAT
CAN’T AFFORD TO BUY THE PPE EVEN
IF IT WERE AVAILABLE.
>> Shannon: QUICKLY TELL US
ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
BECAUSE YOU ARE TAKING $10
DONATIONS, HOW CAN PEOPLE GET
INVOLVED?
>> PLEASE DONATE TO BETHANY/BE
STRONG.
THE SMALL DONATIONS DO ADD UP.
POSTING AS THE MEDIA AND THE
CONNECTIVITY, AND WE ARE
TRANSPARENT.
YOU CAN LOOK AT MY INSTAGRAM AND
SEE EXACTLY WHERE EVERY DOLLAR
GOES, 100% GOES TO THE EFFORT.
NOW MY PARTNERS AND I ARE
WORKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WORKING TO SAVE OUR LIVES.
>> Shannon: WE’VE LOVED
WATCHING YOU DO THIS IN
PUERTO RICO AND MANY OTHER
HARD-HIT AREAS.
WHEN YOU ARE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
AND CALL UP CELEBRITY FRIENDS,
THAT ALL OF US CAN WEIGH IN AND
HELP AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
IT INSPIRES THE REST OF US.
>> THANK YOU AND THE AMERICANS
HELPING ARE NOT AVERAGE AT ALL.
THEY ARE MAKING THIS HAPPEN AND
MADE ME AWARE OF IT.